[Music]
in not so happy ending news sad jackoff
session huh bye Bananarama homeless
veteran who went viral after a couple
helped him raise money is back on the
streets what that's that saying you can
give what's the fish you catch a fish or
teach a man to fish some [ __ ] like that
yeah if you don't like fish he never
gonna get a he's allergic you might kill
him I think they know over time you know
I think I think we got it right here you
know we do this on jakey news we did so
do you guys remember he gave gas money
so get him a fish too yeah this homeless
man gave his last 22 this girl to buy
gas because she was stranded so he
helped her out and then the couple
started a GoFundMe and it blew up and
they got him like six figures or
something right in that picture it's
like who's the homeless they all just
look like they're easy I think you can
tell I know I couldn't they just look
like a bunch of homie they look like
they go hang out at the coffee shop - no
no the guy looks pretty yeah yeah the
guy on the left looks like a wise yo
oh yeah and over our X and then he lost
it it was two hundred almost no it was
three something what state this is a big
deal
yeah raised over four hundred thousand
and they split it or they gave it to him
again the time they raised all this
money but I'm skeptical to get him home
his name is Johnny by the way Johnny is
telling media outlets that he only
received a very small portion of the
money in that now he has run out of
money Oh
livin on the streets again and then he's
back on drugs again Oh of getting their
home in car that he was promised that he
was living in a camper on the couple's
property and that he was giving it given
a broken-down SUV so this is all from
his side right yeah so the couple is
saying that they're withholding the
money so they gave him about a hundred
thousand oh [ __ ] that's a lot of it yeah
and that he blew it all because he
doesn't know how to manage his money and
that now he's just back on drugs and
they said that they will not give him my
anymore until he's off of drugs because
giving him more money would be like
giving him a loaded gun yeah they're
just paying taxes on this money I don't
know about the Texas but Johnny is suing
the couple and now they're gonna be he
has money - that's gonna take it up or
free and endure the lawyers gonna end up
taking like half of that money or
whatever you know what are you like I
invested it guys come on seriously it's
so sad that like what started off as
such a nice gesture and they became
friends became this thing that the
public supported and they got 400,000
and now it's turning into a lawsuit
that's why people call me a cold-hearted
bastard not actually no one calls me
that but then it's just that I feel like
a cold cold dirty bastard are you cold
dirty batts you cold-hearted bastard you
just named a rapper but what I'm trying
to get at is that's why these are the
exact reasons why I do not want to give
too much to people that haven't earned
it yeah because they're saying that they
gave him 25 thousand it's a lot hoped at
all and he blew it in under two weeks
investment
I mean people gotta think about it like
there's a reason why people are homeless
there's a reason why Johnny is also
claiming that this couple that they have
gone and a whole bunch of trips and that
they got a brand-new car their own job
that they have and yeah he's through
that money that they raise for him but
the couple's life we have our own money
we spent our own mini money all he all
he has to do is get it audited that's it
yeah like you you figure out if they
siphon money into their bank account and
where they used in cash like whatever
money they gave him they gave in cash so
maybe he could be like well I didn't get
this amount there is this I mean that
what says there's another city where
it's like money is the root of some all
evil I also think they should just stuck
to their end of the deal just give it to
him anyway okay it's like yeah if he's
gonna die give us technically if it's a
gift
yeah you're not trying to receive
anything back meaning if you give it to
them you can't expect them to spend it
they know what that's like every agent
parent ever like I gave you this so you
shall which it's trading it's not really
giving ya right so it's like I think if
you said that we're raising this money
to give to this person it shouldn't
matter whatever that number is
you should still stand by what you do
yeah but if you're struggling and you're
like oh [ __ ] because if that was the
case I would just go here's the half a
million dollars you whatever you do with
it is you is you yeah what I don't
understand is if it was to buy my house
how come they couldn't just buy all my
house with that money that doesn't make
any sense
there's like did they think she was
gonna [ __ ] refi it and just go smoke
crack I don't know and if he does go
[ __ ] cares just let him do it
yeah and the other odd part is that they
said that they were gonna set him up
with the financial adviser and a trust
to invest and manage his money wait I
don't know what happened to that so
maybe they do got money they decided
they were gonna do it themselves I guess
which is stupid maybe when they came by
that kind of money no they were like
damn yeah they started having mmm what
should we do with this I know it kind of
crowd fund it that's a little over 1
million Taco as a jack-in-the-box
all you get comes to in a dollar and the
dollar thousand dollars just bright in
your bank account right now what would
you do I could spend it immediately Wow
or I can save it too I'm really good at
blowing money spend the first thing that
you would do with it is have to be the
whole thing but the first thing are you
going from nothing to something I have
and I put it all in investments but I
think about the perspective of literally
having nothing and then also in all
sentences 100 racks right there actually
and a motor home and a rope truck
yup so what would you do with it sell
those two vehicles add to the money get
a nice hotel until I figured out what I
want to do with the hundred grand well
technically a little bit more on 400 no
cuz he only got 100 K min to your bank
account right now well he doesn't have a
bank account
whoa am i a crackhead I'll tell you
exactly what I'm gonna do if I was a
crackhead [ __ ] I'll be like hell yeah
I'll call all my crack buddies what
[ __ ] smoke all day dude hell yeah
are you sure yeah that means I got it's
not that fun if you smoke in the lawn
I'll call my crack dealing I'll be like
hey don't even [ __ ] break it up give
me the biggest stone crack like just one
big piece you like how'd you use your
phone back on yeah I just want big stone
piece of crack dude I would have the
biggest crack party prelude to come out
in like you know how like sushi on a
lady like it'll just be like crack on a
hooker with like nothing mean and just
like everything do now it's not even a
cell phone you call the [ __ ]
paper cup and a shoestring if he picks
up then he probably got problem to fix
up how'd you get this paper cup number
yeah it depends on who I am as a human
being you know if you tell me now [ __ ]
up I'd be responsible with it but if I
was mr. cracky what's different I think
he's a crack you major I don't know it's
what his choice of drug is but that just
kinda is the default drug of the
homeless crew is the homeless guy saying
that he also agrees that they gave him
$100,000 no cuz you said he gave him a
little bit yeah that's what he said
well a little bit could be $100,000 out
of 400,000 yeah depending on his
perspective I feel like his standard
rose once he got money because he's like
ungrateful for his truck and his place
of stay when he didn't have any of it
it's true I'm happy you rose of
standards that's good yeah yeah they're
saying that now that they had roughly to
two hundred thousand left hundred for
this headache I would just give it to
him yeah take it take a hundred and
fifty thousand yeah I have no idea why
they're holding on to it he's obviously
as my left though cuz he got a lawyer
yeah a couple are saying that they will
open the book to show where this anyway
that's dope they probably didn't jack
any then it might be the crack talk to
us well you know if I got in a fight
with that homeless dude and I had that
400,000 oh I would rub that [ __ ] in his
face and I would give it away to
something else I'll give it to like
[ __ ] starving children's charity or
some [ __ ]
and I'll be like in-your-face [ __ ] you
just gave away 400,000 to these hungry
kids
now what phone call to my lawyer real
quick yeah let me do it he wants with it
hey just let me do it everyone well what
if you gave him that four hundred
thousand and he had the crack buffet
right or whatever like I like I like a
heroin faster whatever in a week later
try it if you don't like yeah so what if
what if you gave that to him right and
then and then you know yet is like
uncontrollable crack spree and they're
like at the end of that week he dies
because of you and not only him like
maybe maybe ten other crack buddies die
or like whatever they got so [ __ ] up
they overdosed and I know you'll
probably hold yeah it's kind of like you
got crack dust and blood on your hands
dude you know to me there's a moral of
the story don't ever go out of your way
to help anyone no don't do crack is a
good one help anybody so that's how I'm
taking away from the story don't help
anyone I think you got to be prepared to
help people and think about like how
you're gonna help them because there's a
lot of people out there that want to but
they don't know that their donations be
[ __ ] up people yeah mr. sandwich guy
Pasadena [ __ ] you got a point though you
ain't gotta you can't give it any men
[Music]